[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue les mesures de
déconfinement annoncé par emmanuel
macron sont elles à la hauteur
on en débat ce soir avec guillaume bigot
bonsoir guillaume politologue et céistes
éditorialiste à ses news
on recommande avec beaucoup de ferveur
votre dernier livre c'est populo phobie
alors c'est une charge en règle contre
la classe dirigeante française que vous
voulez remplacer
mais derrière cette charge en règle vous
établissez un parallèle passionnant
entre la situation actuelle et celle de
la révolution française ou bien
également celles que l'on voit au moment
de la commune c'est très intéressant on
apprend plein de choses et c'est
remarquablement bien écrit
bon ben vous reviendrez en attendant un
attendant de revoir guillaume vous
pouvez vraiment d'urgence lire ce livre
populo phobie c'est aux éditions plon
tribune libre et on attend avec
impatience le futur livre de ferghana
ziari publication prévue en octobre en
attendant dans la joie on a la joie
d'avoir l'auteur et qui est chercheur
pour le think tank libéral iref je vous
propose de revenir ce soir fergane
guillaume et vous qui êtes avec nous qui
nous fait le plaisir d'être avec nous je
salue notamment nathan 770 qui viennent
nous rejoindre je vous propose de
revenir sur la polémique de la semaine
les réactions et les sanctions à
l'encontre des agents généraux et
militaires qui ont signé une tribune
dénonçant le délitement de la société
ils ont reçu le soutien d'une majorité
des français pour autant les sanctions
qui ont été décidées par florence parly
la ministre des armées et les chefs
d'état major des armées le général
françois lecointre vous sont-elles
illogique sont-elles injustifiée
je vous on vous pose la question sur
twitter et je vous propose d'en débattre
ce soir mais d'abord d'abord revenir
donc sur ces infos que noms qui ont été
dévoilées et sur lesquels ont déjà
revenu
dévoilée avec 12 heures d' avance et
bien entendu ces différentes étapes de
déconfinement on retient donc ces
fameuses quatre étapes de déconfinement
vous les voyez et on retient aujourd'hui
que eh bien on a déjà des exceptions
huit départements sept en ile-de-france
et les bouches du rhône qui pourrait
être d confiné mais plus tard plus tard
que le 19 mai c'est la deuxième étape on
va essayer de revenir charlotte barre
ayant et marc landré ils sont revenus ce
matin vous pouvez voir les extraits du
live qui décortique un peu toutes ces
mesures ce qu'on a eues aujourd'hui en
tous les cas c'est aussi l'explication
de texte d' emmanuel macron extraits et
si les chiffres baissent le virus
circule encore il faudra donc continuer
dans les jours les semaines à venir à
tenir à résister et même si nous allons
progressivement réouvrir dans un
calendrier que je viens de présenter il
faudra jusqu'à cet été
résister ensemble et continuer à
accepter pas simplement les gestes et
les comportements que nous connaissons
mais quelques restrictions pour ralentir
ce virus alors des restrictions pour
ralentir ce virus guillaume ya rien de
neuf mais il ya du bon sens dans ce que
vient de dire le président un public non
ça va ça va dans le bon sens ça c'est
sûr ça va dans le sens d'un allègement
des restrictions des mesures dont on ne
peut que s'en féliciter
mais je trouve quelque chose qui est
vraiment frappant est caractéristique de
la façon de faire de monsieur macron
peut-être même à dire de ceux de ce
pouvoir là c'est à dire c'est un mélange
entre nous prendre un peu pour des
idiots depuis le départ il ya une mule
multiples illustrations de ça et puis
quelque chose de très technocratique
c'est à dire que l'annoncent ccc voit la
cdu en même temps ça en même temps on
déconfinement en même temps on les
confine pas vraiment et on a des
garde-fous en même temps on donne une
date mais en même temps d'1 4 dates
c'est quelque chose qui n'est qui est
tout sauf claire au point où
il est vous l'avez dit dans la
présentation de l'extrait
il faut que le président de la
république face et sous titre commente
en quelque sorte donc on a vraiment
l'impression d'un exercice
technocratique
tout ça n'est pas idiot d'ailleurs quand
on regarde les mesures les unes après
les autres c'est pas idiot mais
néanmoins c'est quand même présenté de
manière assez techno et simultanément il
ya quelque chose de très simple
probablement à dire c'est qu'on a
abandonné finalement une logique
purement sanitaire est principalement
sanitaire est une mesure restrictive que
d'aucuns caricature en parlant d'
enfermer et on a n'ont pas lâché les
chiens mais on a dit finalement que
maintenant il fallait apprendre à vivre
avec le virus
donc voilà ça serait une façon je vens
respectueuse pour les français de dire
aux français écoutez nous avons changé
de fusil d'épaulé
finalement on considère que ce qu'il est
parce que les indicateurs qui justifiait
des mesures sanitaires qui sont levés
aujourd'hui progressivement étaient plus
importants que les indicateurs
d'aujourd'hui qui finalement ne
justifierait pas la levée de ces mesures
donc dire très simplement mais khune
finalement on a changé de logique on a
changé de logique fergane votre point de
vue sur ce qu'on vient d'entendre et sur
ce que vient de dire guillaume sur le
principe même d'un déconfinement moi je
suis tout à fait favorable puisque ça
fait maintenant un an que je dénonce
justement le confinement et que
j'interrogeais sur la possibilité que
ces mesures fasse plus de bien que de
mal je suis d'accord avec aujourd'hui
des contradictions un peu technocratique
d' emmanuel macron même si j'y vois
davantage une forme d'incertitude
vis-à-vis de son propre calendrier parce
qu'on sait très bien que la une prudence
certaine peur parce que il sait aussi
que dans la sphère dans le corps médical
et bien cet agenda ne fait absolument
pas de consensus les médecins lui
reproche de confiner 2d confinés par
dont beaucoup trop tôt vous êtes
d'accord avec les médecins non moi je
vous connais vous comprenez leur point
de vue je comprends leur point de vue
mais en même temps je pense que le corps
médical depuis un an est complètement
aveuglés par le l'indicateur par la
circulation du virus en oubliant que la
santé d'une population son bien-être sa
prospérité fait aussi appel à d'autres
variables
on a longtemps opposé de manière un peu
artificielle la santé et l'économie moi
j'ai toujours jugé cette opposition
stupide parce que je ne connais pas en
réalité un peuple
dont la santé n'est pas d'une manière ou
d'une autre liées voir subordonné à
l'économie l'exemple que je prends
régulièrement c'est que si en afrique
subsaharienne où vivent 20 ans de moins
qu'en europe occidentale
c'est bien pour des raisons économiques
principalement les chiffres les
indicateurs internationaux suggère que
les restrictions sanitaires ont créé des
centaines de millions de pauvres à
travers le monde
combien d'années d'espérance de vie at
on ôter à ces populations
personne n'a fait ce chiffrage donc je
crois qu'il devient en effet urgent de
lever les restrictions
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il faille
faire preuve de laxisme vis-à-vis de la
pandémie qu'il faille baisser la garde
il faut évidemment accélérées la
campagne de vaccination
il faut peut-être autoriser les
entreprises et les commerçants à mettre
en oeuvre une sorte de passe sanitaires
pour conditionner l'accès à certains
lieux la vaccination mais l'idée c'est
qu'on ne peut pas lutter contre une
pandémie à n'importe quel prix et le
prix de la suspension des libertés
fondamentales commencé à être trop
élevées au sein de l'opinion publique
alors nathan nous dit que ferghana bien
raison comme toujours en voie de quel
côté penche nathan françois nous dire en
revanche trente mille cas par jour et on
commence à rouvrir
alors qu'en février s'il y avait 5000
cas par jour et il fallait tout fermé
ben oui ça c'est vraiment c'est ce que
j'appelais changé son fusil d'épaulé
c'est à dire prendre le critère
sanitaires comme critère de décision
principale et puis ensuite prendre le
critère économique et social et
l'acceptabilité comme le critère de
décision essentielle de niaouli mise
tout ça n'est pas aussi simple il faut
combiner les deux critères et c'est pas
faux si je me fais l'avocat du président
de la république il en a pas besoin mais
enfin bon pour aller un peu à l'encontre
ce que je faisais connaître la
programmation du procureur dans ce oui
on y souligne barry watts consommés
millions d'euros sur rennes le mans est
parti très dur mais je crois que compte
tenu des airs en cd et remonte ce
gouvernement heureusement qu'il est
aussi beaucoup d'avocats finalement de
la légitimité démocratique à défaut de
le pavillon de l'adhésion politique donc
en fait ce qu'on peut dire c'est que la
situation est différent parce qu'il ya
un nombre de vaccinés quand même plus
important est que en réalité le monde
songe in inaugurale du pouvoir mais
c'est pas que de ce pouvoir de nombreux
pouvoirs c'est de considérer que cette
maladie qui est en fait très dangereuse
pour une catégorie de la population
on l'a transformé en peste noire et on a
utilisé
si vous voulez un effet de panique parce
que à des fins aussi politique c'est sûr
c'est pas un tramway nommé désir c'est
un co vide
c'est un trou noir ne la regardent
tomber finalement dans cette affaire de
copies des toutes les questions ont été
réduites à la question du comité ans là
où je suis un petit peu moins d'accord
avec moins sévère avec vidéo que
guillaume sais que je ne suis pas
convaincu qu'il ya une
instrumentalisation du virus à des fins
politiques
moi ça va je ne suis pas le plus on va
dire que je suis d'habitude très
critique à l'égard de l'état de nos
gouvernements
mais je pense cette fois-ci qu'ils ont
été dépassés par une pression populaire
et la pression de l'opinion publique et
du corps médical
quand vous avez à la télé tous les soirs
des médecins qui jouit d'un certain
prestige auprès de la population et qui
disent en fermer tout le monde enfermé
tout le monde il est difficile pour pour
emmanuel macron et les autres de ne pas
écouter les plus bruyants et c'est là où
je pense qu'il faut aussi remettre en
question finalement notre propre
conception de la liberté et voir à quel
point le peuple français a capitulé sur
des principes essentiels mais c'est plus
les citoyens que nous sommes tous que
j'aurais tendance à accuser et non pas
le gouvernement je ne suis pas certain
qu'ils aient enfermé de gaieté de coeur
c'est ce que je voulais dire on n'a pas
dit ça rend une autre question qui se
pose et c'est la polémique en ce moment
tous les cas après l'annonce hier après
midi
après que les premières informations et
ont été divulgués la polémique concerne
le pass sanitaires je vois nicole qui
salue et qui est là depuis le début de
l'émission qui nous dit impasse
sanitaires pour prendre l'avion à aller
à l'étranger d'accord mais pas plus qu'à
des votre votre point de vue votre avis
sur la question fergane je pense qu'il
ya déjà deux éléments s'il s'agit pour
l'état de dire vous ne pouvez pas
circuler si vous n'avez pas été vacciné
je pense que ce serait une atteinte
disproportionnée aux libertés publiques
parce que tout le monde n'a pas la même
aversion au risque
face à ce virus tout le monde n'a pas
n'est pas concernée de la même manière
et donc il serait je crois inique et
inefficace d'imposer une solution comme
ça de manière uniforme et jacobine en
revanche on pourra me rétorquer à juste
titre que la liberté des uns s'arrête là
où commence celle des autres c'est une
conception et une conception de la
liberté mais je suis tout à fait savoir
juste à mon avis et qui implique que les
citoyens les particuliers des
entreprises doivent être capables de
décider
chez eux à leur échelle sur quels
critères finalement ils accueillent leur
clientèle leurs collaborateurs donc moi
je ne serais pas choqué par exemple
qu'on laisse les restaurateurs décidée
pour leur restaurant s'il conditionne
l'accès à leur établissement au fait
d'être vacciné ça pourrait être un
argument commercial venez chez nous
parce que ici vous avez la certitude que
toute la clientèle et tous les
collaborateurs sont vaccinés mais je
pense qu'il faut une approche
décentralisée pour permettre à chacun
finalement de choisir librement le
risque auquel il veut s'exposer
étant entendu que moi je indépendamment
des restrictions étatique je continue
d'encourager à la vaccination
auprès de mes proches je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut promouvoir mais
je suis toujours sceptique à l'idée
d'utiliser la coercition de manière un
peu centralisée pour imposer une mesure
par principe alors sur le principe donc
faire gagner contre le pass sanitaire
mais ça peut souffrir d exception c'est
au bon endroit des des particuliers des
personnes morales peuvent en avoir
besoin votre point de vue d'abord je
pense qu'à une confusion entre
l'obligation de la vaccination elle pas
sanitaire c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose à dire que le pass sanitaire ça
peut être aussi d'avoir été testées
négatives
oui et ça c'est fondamental d'avoir même
les antilles d'avoir une sérologie qui
montre qu'on a les anticorps exactement
soit vous la maladie est vous a déjà
traversé vous avez développé des
anticorps
soit vous n'avez pas la maladie dans les
72 heures soit alors vous avez été
vaccinées moi ça ne me choque pas parce
qu a pas d'obligation de se soigner et
d'obligation de se vacciner
la question de l'obligation de la
vaccination est encore une autre
question
c'est pas d'un point de vue des
principes c'est pas choquant mais il
faudrait que les choses soient posées
clairement sur la table le président de
la république n'a pas été élu avec ce
genre de mandat et il n'a pas
l'autorisation aux semble-t-il le mandat
démocratique pour faire ça si un
président un futur président ou une
présidente se présente en disant écoutez
moi si je suis élu je vais imposer la
vaccination
mais si le peuple français se prononcent
pour la vaccination alors d'accord c'est
pas le cas ce serait vraiment quelque
chose de très très très intrusif et le
trait non seulement ça violerait les
libertés individuelles mais ça viendrait
aussi les libertés collectives ça
atteindrait vraiment à nos principes
or il ya déjà eu des tentatives de ceux
de ce genre il ya eu plusieurs projets
de loi qui ont été déposées
on sait que ça traîne donc non pas que
l'obligation de vacciner elle est même
pas je répète elle n'est pas choquant en
tant que tel il ya des pays dans
lesquels vous ne pouvez pas d'ailleurs
vous rendre si vous n'avez pas les
autorités locales demandent en dehors du
coc vide
nous serons dans certains pays si vous
n'avez pas été vaccinés avec steve
rejoint dans la vienne rejoindre en
afrique dans certains pays tropicaux on
vous demande d'avoir été vacciné cias et
ça c'est alors on va peut-être une
distinction ça c'est aux frontières là
on est plus orienté leurs aînés on n'est
plus à ça serai là je rejoins
parfaitement
mon contradicteur ça serait totalement
inique d'empêcher de ralentir de freiner
la vie quotidienne des gens
d'empoisonner la vie quotidienne des
gens avec un pass à lithaire je vous
pose une question je suis peut-être
nicole comme les virus quels qu'ils
soient circulent en permanence
on ne peut pas accepter ces restrictions
en permanence il y a eu toute une
polémique dans les années 80 et 90 au
tour justement
il n'y avait pas de vaccin il n'y a pas
de vaccins et des traitements sont quand
même assez limité pour les personnes
atteintes du vih les personnes atteintes
du sida avec parfois l'interdiction
enfin les états unis avaient évoqué
l'idée d'interdire l'accès aux personnes
et raja atteints du vih et on avait
dénoncé des mesures discriminatoires et
le consensus a été qu'on a renoncé
l'ensemble de ces mesures
justement pour ne pas être
discriminatoire
est-ce que ce consensus est pas
justement battu en brèche avec une
mesure comme le passeport sanitaires
aujourd'hui le consensus est battu en
brèche et en même temps je sais pas si
la comparaison est vraiment automnal
parce que bon le vih si vous ne pouviez
pas avec une personne atteinte du virus
est quand même difficile de l'attraper
ici on est face à un virus qui est d'
une contagiosité plus forts dont on peut
peut-être comprendre que le sujet se
pose ceci dit je pense en effet que le
principe doit rester le même c'est à
dire que la liberté individuelle exige
que l'on renonce à imposer un pass
sanitaires pour tout le monde
indépendamment du consentement des
propriétaires des lieux des
établissements mais ce n'est pas
finalement ci ne veut pas dire encore
une fois que la société est laxiste à
dire que on peut tout à fait imaginer un
monde finalement où les citoyens étant
responsable sentant responsable de leur
propre santé et de la santé de ceux dont
ils ont la charge par exemple dans les
hôpitaux mais ça ne choquerait pas que
les propriétaires ou les établissements
où les gestionnaires d'hôpitaux de
cliniques de maisons de retraites bien
sûr et bien oblige l'heure leurs
employés à se vacciner ça me veut ça me
même mon avis la moindre des choses donc
il faut vraiment mon avis regarder les
choses cas par cas faire preuve
appliquer le principe de subsidiarité
tout simplement et se dire que
l'application d'un principe de
précaution doit se faire de la manière
la plus localisés pour si possible pour
correspondait bien aux différentes
situations
mais ce serait pas divertir si et
seulement si ça se fait dans ces
conditions là effectivement danette
et kris kross nathan sont d'accord en
dix ans le vih ne s'attrapait pas comme
ça ça ne se passera pas comme la grippe
effectivement il ya un principe de
proportionalité qui est d'abord sur la
question du sida
on a pour ce pour le plus ancien et qui
ont connu l'apparition de ce cette
terrible maladie
il ya eu quand même beaucoup de
fantasmes et d'irrationalité collective
au sujet du sida et la poussière est
retombée un moment et on a retrouvé un
peu de raison dans la manière
d'appréhender les malades la circulation
des malades etc
ensuite je pense qu'il ya un principe de
proportionalité c'est à dire que si
cette 6e qu'ovide 19 avait 30 40 50% de
taux de létalité on n'aurait pas ce
débat
personne ne discuterait du caractère
obligatoire de la vaccination
dupas sanitaires etc ce serait pas du
tout un débat pourquoi il ya un débat et
parce qu'il ya bien sûr il ya depuis le
départ il ya eu une disproportion
manifeste entre la réaction des
autorités
le discours sanitaire finalement et puis
la réalité de la menace du danger que
comme la fin qu'on oblige et soignants
par exemple les médecins et les
soignants et sert à se vacciner très
bien enfin moi je trouve serait pas
choquant ils sont au contact de
personnes à risque très vulnérable que
même les personnes à risque pour frais
pour limiter ce finalement ces mesures
on les prend pourquoi on les prend pour
protéger 20 30% de la population
vulnérable et donc ont d'ailleurs nous
le vend comme ça on nous vend cela comme
un effort de de solidarité à l'égard des
vins ou des 30% le plus vulnérable donc
on fait ce qu'il faut pour protéger les
biens ou les 30% venir mais d'abord pour
commencer peut-être les obligés de se
vacciner eux les 20 ou les 30%
vulnérables mais ce qui est complètement
fou c'est prendre en otage 80 ou 70 % la
population qui en réalité n'est pas
concerné donc on va je ne sais pas j'ai
pas de boule de cristal je suis pas
médecin mais il est probable quand même
que cette affaire de coheed revient à
une sorte de grippe beaucoup plus grave
en fait que la grippe est beaucoup plus
létal que la grée quatre fois peut-être
cinq fois plus létal que la grippe donc
il y aura des vaccins parce que ras des
variants et ont vécu nérac imac signera
les gens qui sont à risque de faire des
formes sérieuse on vaccinera sans doute
pas tout le monde je donne encore au jeu
c'est le chardon bleu qui est en train
de nous
indre et les réactions de
que vous nous avez partagé
paul le variant indien arrive mais tout
va bien on rouvre tout nathan 770 le
cocktail vaccinal pour aller en afrique
ok c'est difficile id on a décidé d
décennie d'utilisation la non et je
petit 74 qui nous partage son impression
que macron à jouer avec nous dit-il en
s'affichant comme le sauveur avant les
élections on vous poser la question les
mesures de déconfinement sont elles
selon vous à la hauteur et vous répondez
non à plus de 60 % à 64 % l'autre
question qu'on pose sur twitter c'est si
les sanctions contre les généraux
signataires de la tribune controversée
publiée d'abord sur le site la place
libre et ensuite chez le confrère de
valeurs actuelles sont injustifiées ce
sont des sanctions lourdes en tout cas
des procédures longues
c'est ce qui se profile pour ses
généraux et ses militaires d'activé
encore en activité qui ont signé cette
tribune c'est en tout cas cette semaine
ce qu'a promis la ministre des armées
florence parly s'agissant de ses
généraux avec le chef d'état major des
armées
nous avons décidé d'engager les
procédures
visant à leur radiation s'agissant des
militaires d'activé ont été repérés dans
la liste des signataires
des sanctions disciplinaires seront
appliquées puisque les militaires sont
astreints pour un respect strict du
devoir de réserve et pour une raison
très simple c'est que l'armée de la
république ne fait pas de politique
l'armée l'a public ne fait pas de
politique alors parmi les réactions
politiques à cette annonce de sanctions
on en retiendra notamment deux sur
twitter notamment celle de jean luc
mélenchon qui s'est réjoui de ces
poursuites et qui a exprimé son respect
alors à l'égard du général du chef
d'état major des armées le général
d'armée de lecointe défend l'honneur de
l'armée de la république face aux
factieux qui se sont déshonorés lepreau
la procureure quand va-t-elle faire son
travail et la garde des sceaux alors
précisément voici la réaction d'une
autre ancienne d'une autre garde des
sceaux dans tous les cas et mérite
l'ancien ministre de la justice rachida
dati
je pense qu'on ne peut pas uniquement
s'attacher au fait de dire nous allons
poursuivre ou sanctionner ces militaires
en oubliant ce qui est écrit ce qui est
écrit c'est une réalité
le sujet effectivement c'est qu'on règle
ce délitement consent part quand même
des problèmes de la france qu'on
rétablisse de l'ordre qu'on remette de
l'autorité qu'on rétablisse la sécurité
qu'on réduise les inégalités
fergane vous êtes plutôt mélenchon vous
êtes plutôt rachida l'a tout d'abord
quand j'ai eu la tribune
je les ai relu à plusieurs reprises je
vous avoue que je lai en effet
interprété comme une sorte de menace
contre les institutions et je ne pense
pas avoir été le plus mauvais en
commentaire de texte quand j'étais au
lycée mais là pour le coup c'est vrai
que les formulations ambiguës le ton un
peu intimidant m'a pas surpris alors
ensuite j'ai entendu les explications de
ceux qui s'ils ont signé ce texte qui se
défend des de tout appel à
l'insurrection alors je veux bien
laisser à ces braves messieurs le
bénéfice du doute mais enfin ya quand
même quelques reformulation quelques
formulations à revoir je pense à un
paragraphe qui dit que si rien n'est
entrepris alors la guerre civile le
mettra fin au chaos je ne comprends pas
comment une guerre civile peut mettre
fin au chaos social on prête aux guerres
civiles des vertus purificatrices ce qui
est quand même assez dans cette
formulation vous pensez que les généraux
soit une guerre s'il écoute et j'en sais
rien je ne suis pas dans la dans la tête
de ses généraux je n'ai pas envie de
leur faire un procès d'intention je
remarque juste que si en tout cas il ne
voulait pas appeler à la guerre civile
dans l'insurrection
il se défend de vouloir appeler à
l'insurrection je trouve en tout cas ce
que le texte est très mal écrit dans ces
conditions parce que beaucoup y compris
des gens de bonne foi je crois qu'ils
ont interprété de manière assez assez
assez assez douteuse maintenant sur le
fond savez tous le caractère un peu à
vrai dire faire à temps déjà on va
revenir sur le fond mais peut-être
est-ce que vous avez vu cette
interprétation également guillaume en
lisant le texte
non et pourtant j'ai pas trouvé ce texte
très fort enfin très très bon en réalité
défonçant un peu des portes ouvertes
parce que ce qui est ce qui est dit sur
les banlieues sur ce qui sur ce qui se
trame et c'est n'est pas très surprenant
enfin tout le monde sait à peu près ce
constat effectivement il ya une formule
qui me paraît très maladroite ou il ya
quasiment moi ce que je reproche
j'ai pas vu ça j'ai pas lu cette formule
mais peut-être qu'à elle y ait deux je
me souviens plus ont peut-être trouvé le
texte
moi ce qui me choque c'est une phrase la
seule phrase qui met vraiment choqué
c'est la phrase où il est dit nos
camarades devront intervenir et en
banlieue sans qu'on sache si ces fameux
camarades c'est à dire des militaires
des officiers s'autosaisir on s'auto
mobiliseront pour y aller ou si le
pouvoir légitime le pouvoir politique
l'ordonnera l'eau est un dialecte
ambiguïté donc il ya une ambiguïté donc
c'est assez maladroit oui et pardonnez
moi mais j'entends quand on lit le texte
mais ça c'est j'ai lu effectivement
c'est la phrase qui est voilà à la fac
en produisant que devant la situation
qui est celle qui décrivent et qu'il
dénonce
la conséquence pour être que les
militaires d'activé soit amené
exactement à conduire cette a
effectivement à agir mais j'ai pas lu je
n'ai pas lu que c'était un souhait et
bien si je n'ai pas lu que c'était alors
annoncées n'ont pas vu que c'était un
souhait et moi même il ya un confrère
qui s'appelle henri vernet du parisien
qui n'a rien d'un putschiste qui a écrit
il ya deux ans un livre à un roman qui
s'appelle article 36 où il imagine que
la france passe ou l'état de siège
militaire qui a été un succès d'édition
et dans lequel il décrit plutôt un un
scénario où c'est les civils qui appelle
signe qu'ils sont au pouvoir qui sont
dépassés qui appelle la polo militaire
était là c'était plutôt c'était plutôt
c'est comme ça dans ce sens là que je
les ai lus mais peut-être que j'étais
biaisé par la lecture de l'excellent
roman de mon confrère mais pas du tout
pas du tout non seulement ils sont ils
en appellent aux principes républicains
dans ce texte enfin les généraux ne sont
pas du tout des factions des putschistes
ils disent au nom des principes de la
république a quelque chose de la
république est en train de se déliter de
manière très grave
donc ça c'est quand même leur faire dire
ce qu'ils n'ont pas dit où le contraire
de ce qu'ils ont voulu dire et
deuxièmement il c'est une formule très
maladroite l'autre chose qui est très
maladroit bien sûr c'est la coïncidence
de dates entre le 21 avril date de
publication dans valeurs actuelles et le
le 60e anniversaire du putsch d'alger 21
avril 1961 mais en dehors de cette
coïncidence mais là les généraux ils
sont vraiment pour rien pour le coup
puisqu'il isabelle bien quoi j'avais
aussi d'animer 3 7 d'intentions
incroyable et je pense que si on a
l'intention de faire un putsch et on se
veut menaçant on n'utilise pas des
circonvolutions et des phrases
complètement alambiqué ambiguë donc
certains se font plaisir et jouer à la
commedia dell'arte comme on joue aux
indiens et aux cow-boys et rejouer
césarisme et à lutter à mains nues
contre le flash et une partie de la une
partie de la gauche pour aller dans le
dos rond pour aller jusqu'au bout de
votre de votre raisonnement est ce cas
vous devrez bien une partie de la classe
politique les partis de la gauche en
particulier de la gauche radicale qui
aiment criait au complot c'est cela
c'est pire que ça c'est que je pense que
l'eau pour finalement il ya quelque
chose via une mise en abyme qui est
terrifiante c'est à dire que la sévérité
du gouvernement la rigueur du
gouvernement à l'égard de ces de ses
généraux des officiers dont on pourrait
dire qu'ils se sont exprimés de manière
maladroite peut-être fait quand même un
contraste très sérieux avec l'impunité
dont jouissent des émeutiers en banlieue
par exemple les islamistes étaient ses
champs forts disait en france on laisse
au repos ce qui met le feu et on
persécute ce qui sonne le tocsin
alors c'est effectivement la première
phrase de la chronique d'eric zemmour
dans le figaro le figaro magazine et il
a peut-être lu votre livre d'enfant
recommande aux [ __ ] cas
la lecture avec lui on entendu chamfort
c'est pour le vendredi lecture s'il
avait voulu faire un putsch midi sylvie
l'aurait fait sans écrire de l'être sur
le fond justement sur ce qui est décrit
puisque guillaume revenus et c'est sur
ça que josé compétiteurs fergie sur le
fond il ya des choses qu'on peut en
effet partagé mais vous savez tout le
caractère un peu pervers de cette
tribune selon moi c'est que l mais là
l'a fait roi oui un petit peu insidieux
on va dire pour être plus plus
sympathique c'est qu'elle mêle à la fois
des préoccupations tout à fait légitime
et en même temps des attaques partisanes
complètement outrancière c'est à dire
que lorsqu'on parle par exemple du péril
islamiste - oui là dessus on est
d'accord je pense pas chaud ce plateau
en minimisera ce risque là moi même je
suis assez critique de la religion
musulmane et pas seulement de l'islam
politique et je pense que ce qu'il faut
déconstruire en tant que tel c'est bien
là la religion musulmane qui est
intrinsèquement un problème lorsqu'il
parle du du père il a dit à des casseurs
des violences urbaines
institutionnalisée oui là aussi on peut
je crois être que d'accord avec cela et
il faudrait aussi interroger cette
complaisance que nous avons vis-à-vis
des black blocks qui au nom d'une
idéologie anti capitaliste casse tout
chaque fois qu'une manifestation
mais quand on va me dire confondent
amalgames et ses périls avec par exemple
des querelles partisanes sur les
mouvements des coloniaux la critique du
roman national alors moi je ne dis pas
que je suis un partisan de ces
mouvements là mais l'amalgamme ici c'est
là où on fait de la politique on fait
plus seulement un constat sécuritaire
alors moi je veux bien que des
militaires participent au débat d'idées
laisse libre court à certaines outrances
mais je ne vois pas pourquoi ils le font
sous la bannière de l'institution
militaire
et c'est là où je trouve qu'en effet la
réaction de la ministre des armées est
tout à fait justifiée ne s'agit pas de
les mettre en prison ou de les
poursuivre pénalement mais de dire si
vous voulez tenir de tels propos on va
dire voilà qui peuvent se discuter
vous n'avez pas à le faire sous la
bannière d'une institution militaire est
un devoir de neutralité
moi je pense que c'est ils ont justement
mis le doigt là où il fallait mettre le
doigt c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas
seulement malheureusement d elie la
phrase quelques que dénonce en tout cas
que critique fergane c'est aujourd'hui
certains parlent de racialisme
indigéniste et au rider coloniale mais à
travers ces termes c'est la guerre
raciale que veulent ses partisans et ne
les fanatiques il maîtrise notre pays
ses traditions sa culture et veulent le
voir se dissoudre en lui arrachant son
passé et son histoire
c'est aussi un peu la thèse que en tous
les cas et taye mathieu bock côté dans
la révolution socialiste
il a parfaitement raison je pense qu'il
ya véritable ce qui fait le danger en
réalité de cette de cette contre culture
qui à la fois une contre-culture du
gangstérisme un peu ethniciser ce qui
n'est pas très nouveau d'ailleurs le
trafic de drogue était tenu par les
corses aujourd'hui tenues par les
maghrébins il ya toujours quelque chose
de d'ethnique dans la mafia mais grosso
modo on n'avait jamais vu la mafia
attaqué la police donc à quelque chose
là dedans qui est vraiment profondément
inquiétant et dont on voit bien qu'il ya
eu un continuum c'est pas la même chose
mais il s'est quand même un continuum
entre d'un côté les coups de boutoir de
l'islamisme plus ou moins bon teint en
tout cas qui est pas nécessairement du
jihadisme de l'entrisme par exemple et
de l'autre côté cette espèce de ce qui
n'est pas non plus du tout une guerre
civile il faut que les mots et un sens
mais qui est un espèce d'état
d'insurrection permanente parce que
justement le fait juste avions résume ce
que je pense que je vais répondre alors
la question est bien ce qui est
dangereux là dedans il y a donc ses
ennemis de la france et de la république
qui se manifeste et il ne serait pas
grand chose finalement
si certains ne venait pas les légitimer
au sommet de la société auront fait il y
à bien une pince identitaire mais ce
n'est pas du tout celle qu'on croit
c'est le président de la république chef
de l'état chef des armées qui parle de
déconstruire l'histoire de france et de
l'autre en bas vous avez des émeutiers
et des islamistes qui avance et c'est ça
quant au terme de la tendance la
critique du roman national ya des
historiens qu'ils ont fait me
semble-t-il c'est une volonté de
finalement d'abaisser ou de relativiser
la france comme un sacré politique pour
pouvoir construire l'europe
au fond c'est ça l'histoire de la nôtre
points et je voudrais juste qu'on
réagisse à 49% des français pensent que
l'armée devrait intervenir sans qu'on
lui en donne l'ordre
mais eux les militaires d'abord des
militaires ça ne veulent pas ccim
certitude
heureusement meilleure fergane comment
il faut répondre selon vous à cette
colère des français et à leurs besoins
d'ordre je parle de colère également ce
que c'est ce que montre le sondage doxa
qui est publié dans le figaro
ces dernières heures mais commencez déjà
par appliquer les lois avec la rigueur
avec laquelle on devrait les appliquer
mais ça ça rejoint tout simplement
l'idée même d'état de droit l'efficacité
des fonctions régaliennes
donc c'est ce que dit dans la tribune
ils font le constat sur ce constat là
ben moi je ne vais pas je fais pas
partie de ceux qui nient l'existence de
ces problèmes je pense aussi qu'au delà
de l'application des fonctions
régaliennes il ya aussi tout un combat
civilisationnel a amené pour
déconstruire les idéologies qui
aujourd'hui s'attaquent à notre
civilisation déconstruire l'islam
politique voire déconstruit la religion
musulmane en tant que tel je lui ai dit
tout à l'heure
déconstruire pas mal de choses les
spécialistes de la déconstruction des
traditions aliénante comme la grammaire
devrait peut-être
d'abord s'attacher à déconstruire des
idéologies autrement plus aliénante et
dangereuses que celles auxquelles elles
s'attaquent aujourd'hui
en revanche je ne confondrait pas la
déconstruction la nécessité de
s'attaquer à tous les périls au fait de
diaboliser par exemple la démarche qui
consiste à remettre en cause ou en
question un certain roman national une
certaine vision l'histoire de france
je ne crois pas que cette attaque est
par exemple la france dans son essence
que de remettre en question par exemple
les la nostalgie impérial que l'on peut
ressentir pour telle ou telle figure tel
ou tel empereur tel ou tel mot nappe
ce sont des débats historiques qui sont
tout à fait sain et je ne vois pas
l'intérêt en fait d'amalgamés ces deux
positions qui n'ont je crois rien à voir
moi vous savez je j'appartiens une
tradition intellectuelle qui est le
libéralisme on au 19e siècle il y avait
un écrivain libéral qui s'appelle ville
s'appelait frédéric bastiat qui disait
qu'il y avait une belle formule tu
disais il ya trop de grands hommes dans
l'histoire de france est dans les temps
de manière générale trop de gens se
place au dessus de l'humanité pour la
régente et je crois je ne crois pas
qu'il faille faire de cette figure la
l'ennemi de notre civilisation
simplement on peut je crois s'attacher
au prestige de notre société et de notre
culture notre civilisation sans pour
autant la confondre avec la gloire des
despotes qui l'ont qui se sont succédé
pour la régente et alors on va peut-être
avoir le débat historique d'être à un
autre un autre jour sur le le fait qu'
il faut appliquer les lois existantes
you and me dit tu as fait d'accord
monsieur à ziaya raison à appliquer la
loi c'est la moitié du chemin qui est
fait c'est votre point de vue bien sûr
que oui bien sûr que les militaires ne
sont pas pour intervenir directement en
banlieue pour prendre une image assez
parlante
j'en parlais avec un d'officiers il est
en fait en réalité utilisé des troupes
qui sont faites pour le combat pour
rétablir l'ordre tout simplement l'ordre
la paix l'ordre civil est la paix dans
les quartiers difficiles ce serait comme
utiliser une tronçonneuse pour faire de
la chirurgie l'exemple est vraiment très
parlant en fait les troupes sont faites
pour détruire
annie l'ennemi et l'éradiquer sont pas
faites pour rétablir l'ordre
donc pour autant effectivement la
question se pose de savoir pourquoi les
fans n'agit pas et pourquoi on laisse
des ordres se propager d'une certaine
façon est pourquoi il est si inefficaces
alors même qu'il capte à moitié de la
richesse nationale alors on rappellera
peut-être aussi que les personnes qui
ont souvent appelée officiellement
l'armée à intervenir
c'est peut-être des gens comme samia
ghali
élus de gauche ou bien historiquement en
algérie c'était également un pouvoir de
gauche
s'il avait voulu faire un pot de sheen
l'aurait fait sans écrire des lettres ne
dit si bien sûr qu'elles sont
injustifiés estime chris kraus il parle
des sanctions contre les militaires en
tous les cas celles qui sont agités par
la ministre des armées le chef d'état
major des armées
en revanche romano lui pense que ces
sanctions sont plus que justifiée non
aux factieux le gouvernement a bien fait
la pub sans le vouloir à cette tribune
estime d'annette 49 les militaires sont
condamnés avant d'être jugé denis
chardons bleus alors selon les
informations et selon nicolas barotte
également qui a travaillé sur la
question correspondant défense du figaro
vous allez pouvoir retrouver l'article
sur le site il ya toute une procédure et
qui risque d'être d'ailleurs assez
longue
avant d'arriver à ses éventuelles
condamnations
il y a une phrase qui est mal régis dit
j'ai peut-être mais tout le reste est
vrai estime nicole le gouvernement
reproche aux militaires de vouloir
sauver la république c'est un paradoxe
incroyable s'insurge nathan 770 ce genre
de tribunes mérite amplement d'être
sévèrement sanctionné steeman inverse
c'est aubrée et nathan encore bref nos
militaires n'ont rien fait de mal et
méritent au contraire considération et
gratitude
c'est en tous les cas un sentiment qui
est partagé par 58% du français selon le
dernier sondage réalisé par harris
interactive pour lci
les sanctions contre les généraux
signataires de la tribune controversées
sont injustifiés ça c'était la question
qu'on vous pose sur twitter et vous
répondez une légère majorité une
majorité à une aiguille à 56%
on rappelle que dans tous les cas c'est
un grand jour pour l'armée vous avez une
autre tribune de militaires à retrouver
sur le site du figaro qui a rien à voir
mais c'est celle qui est écrite par le
lieutenant-colonel ponticelli le petit
fils du dernier poilu et qui est
légionnaires et qui rend hommage iran
qui rend hommage au légionnaire tombé le
30 avril 1863 à cameron ils étaient 62
face à deux mille cavaliers et la
légende dit que le soleil baissa les
yeux quand ils furent tous exterminés
voilà pourquoi le légionnaire souvent
honneur et patrie
quant à nous sur point de vue là les
devises l'une des devises de la légion
laquelle on se référera c'est être et
durer on se retrouve lundi avec le
retour cette fois ci de guillaume
roquette et on envoie notre salut
également à guillaume bernard et on
espère vite le revoir parmi nous à très
vite sur fear alive
merci beaucoup s'est passé une vitesse
supersonique
[Musique]